all right smoothie bowls yep their
smoothie bowls are the latest breakfast
trends smoothie bowls and here with
three quick and easy recipes
abby sharp is with us today nice to see
you again
we were just chatting about you know
smoothies are great but they're like
drive-through you get up you go you run
and you're saying that
these are what well it allows you to be
more mindful
and you know it's it's so much more
emotionally satiating
to sit down to a nice healthy meal right
rather than drink those liquid calories
and just run out the door yeah and i
know sometimes we have to do that but
the whole mindfulness thing is really
happening right now very so let's talk
about the first one you're going to do
yes so we got a green matcha berry bowl
so
this is for those days maybe you need a
little extra nutrition you want to pack
it all
into one big bowl so this is greek
yogurt of course
lots of protein some skim skim milk so
we've got
lots of good nutrition going in there
we've got some
beautiful baby spinach for making it
green
lots of antioxidants all in there as
well
avocado which is such a favorite of mine
yeah it makes everything taste better
me too bananas frozen bananas add
sweetness
but also of course add a little bit of
texture it thickens things up nicely
some lemon juice just a splash also
helps it from getting you know oxidated
this is that matcha green tea powder see
look at that let's
look at that and and so where do you get
that you can get it at your health food
store in a lot of kind of specialty food
stores as well all right i'm finding it
in the tea section often
so just a little bit just a little bit
half a teaspoon it adds um
all those catechin antioxidants really
important and then a touch of honey just
to
you know sweeten that up to taste and
then of course
we're going to blend that it smells so
good i love that green tea
it smells like the green tea uh
let's get that going
nice and thick nice and thick because
you've got to eat it with a spoon
and this is the fun part we get to
decorate so you want you eat with your
eyes first so we want this of course to
look appealing and we get to make it
pinterest worthy
insta instagram ready right yeah all
right so a little bit in there
perfect so that's our green and we're
gonna have some fun with the
with the berries so some blueberries
some raspberries
lots of antioxidants of course that's
what this is all about
getting those beautiful colors in there
some pomegranate seeds
some goji berries i love these why do
you love them so much
they're just they're packed with those
antioxidants and they
they have nice chewy consistency like
raisins like raisins and that's what
this is about it's about those textural
contrasts
which you can't get with an actual
smoothie this is some chia seeds so a
little sprinkle
chia seeds obviously you've got fiber
protein healthy fats
so beautiful and there you go sit down
and have breakfast
yummy yummy and it's filling too so
it's filling yeah you won't you won't
you will go to work or or school hungry
exactly now i like this one pumpkin pie
protein bowl that's how you're talking
yeah there it is right there tell us how
what's in there so same kind of
technique going on it started with skim
milk
the fat-free plain greek yogurt the
frozen banana right this i'm adding
a canned pumpkin so of course it's
pumpkin pie
but you know pumpkin spice everything
these days so i want to hop on that
bandwagon
so we're just going to put the pumpkin
in there we've got a scoop of protein
powder for those days maybe you need a
little extra
something in there from a hard workout
and then we decorate so you know we've
got some apples in here apple a day
apple a day and we've got a double duty
so there's some dried apple for some
nice
a chewy consistency some pumpkin seeds i
love these healthy fats
and that's what this is about you know
you want to get that combination of fat
and protein right so what seeds
should we have on hand like you're you
know we're talking about chia we're
talking about pumpkin
juice hearts have a little bit exactly
something that has some fiber protein
and healthy fats very good chocolate
peanut butter and banana bowl i'd wake
up for that yeah
i would wake up for that all right so
yeah it's a universal favorite
combination that peanut butter chocolate
banana combination
but it can also make a really healthy
breakfast as well so what did you just
put in there so
oats went in some water and some skim
milk we're going to switch this up from
the traditional smoothie bowl and do
another breakfast bowl because
sometimes it gets a little bit cooler
the months ahead so we want to
have another alternative some natural
peanut butter
protein fiber healthy fats that's the
combination that's going to keep you
feeling fuller
longer we've got some mashed up ripe
banana for some natural sweetness
a little tiny pinch of salt because
that's i always want to add salt to your
uh
to your oats why is that it just brings
out the flavor it'll always taste flat
if you
if you avoid it okay so very good always
put that in there and then some natural
cocoa powder you know
a teaspoon or two or maybe half a cup
depending on what your day is looking
like
you know whatever you need to get you
through zippy exactly
and then yeah we now we get to decorate
again so we're going to just what
does that take well how long would that
taste this will only take once it kind
of comes up to a boil
it will literally only take a couple
minutes two minutes on the on the
stovetop yeah so then we decorate we've
got some bananas
we've got some peanuts for some crunch
and again for that that satiety factor
yeah
i love that oh and these are cocoa nibs
i'm sure you've seen the cocoa nibs
there yeah really
oh they're so great they add a nice
crunch they add that chocolate fix
factor
yeah but they're a lot healthier they're
unprocessed so that you get that
the chocolate flavor without all the
sugar and the fat
so these breakfast bowls are are great
because they are filling
you are you like you see you're being
mindful when you're when you're eating
it
and but they are they like you shouldn't
be hungry like three hours after
is that the proportion that you want
yeah i mean that's all you need that's
all you need because it's
it's so heavily concentrated with all
that flavor and nutrition right
abby sharp everybody see it sharp
there you go eat healthy that's the way
to do it we do have to take a break
we'll be back right after this